[MUSIC PLAYING]
Writing good tests
can be a challenge.
And writing reliable UI
tests, it's substantially more
difficult. User interfaces
are asynchronous,
driven by events,
transitions, and data
loaded from background threads.
Coding around that without
any help from a UI testing
framework would require a lot
of boilerplate and handling
of edge cases.
On the other hand, say I give
you a phone with a sample app
and tell you to test
a feature of the app
that I just implemented.
For example, please make
sure that saving a new note
in my note-taking app works.
What would you do?
Well, I'm pretty sure that you
would look for a Save button.
Once you've found
it, you'd tap on it
and then check if the note
is present in the list
of saved notes.
That's actually a pretty
good scenario for a UI test,
and it's simple to
understand for a person.
But how would we go about
expressing it in code?
The Espresso framework
was created specifically
for this purpose--
to enable developers
to write UI tests that are
concise, reliable, and using
a fluent API.
And most importantly, Espresso
takes care of synchronization
with any UI events so
that, in most cases,
you don't have to worry about
any view state transitions
and implementation details.
Looking back at the simple
UI test we just defined,
we can see that the basic
flow when using Espresso
is exactly the same as in
our real-life scenario.
First, find a view using
some matching rules.
Then perform an action on it.
And finally, verify
the resulting state.
Before I go any further and
start writing actual test code,
let's make sure that
the Android test
runner and Espresso dependencies
are configured in build.gradle.
I'll add the dependencies
and set up the runner here.
If you're using a version
of Android Studio that
lets you select
the test artifact,
remember to switch to
Android instrumentation
test under Build Variants.
I'm using Android
Studio 2.0, which
has a combined view for both
local and instrumentation
tests.
So I can already see
both in my project view.
Instrumentation tests go under
the Android test source set.
So I'll create a
sample test class here
and name it NotesScreenTest.
I have to add an annotation
on the test class to specify
that I'll be writing
Junit 4 tests
and running them with the
Android Junit 4 runner.
The note screen in
our app is contained
in the notes activity.
By adding an activity
test rule, I'm
telling the runner to launch
the activity before any test
and turn it down
after they finish.
All of this is taken
care of with this line.
Now I'll add a new
method with a descriptive
name for the actual test and
start with the basic structure
I explained before.
Notice that onView is actually
a method on the Espresso class.
But across my testing code,
I will use static imports
to be able to express the
tests in a more concise way.
All right.
Let's go through
the arguments next.
We need a matcher in order to
find a view in the current view
hierarchy.
Espresso comes with a
set of built-in matchers
for common view properties
like With ID, With Text,
Is Checked, and many others.
We provide a simple
cheat sheet so you
don't have to go digging through
the documentation every time.
In my case, I want to locate the
floating action button, which
fortunately is the only item
on the screen with the ID
fab_add_notes.
Now that I've isolated the view
that I need using matchers,
it's time to apply
a view action,
or in other words,
a user interaction
that will be
simulated by Espresso.
I just want to click the FAB.
But again, there are many more
built-in actions, like typing
and even finger swipes, that I
can use to interact with views.
And finally, I verify
the outcome of my actions
by using a view assertion.
Since I want to check if
an input field is shown
on screen after
pressing the fab,
I'll move this
block of code here.
And I use the matches assertion
that accepts a view matcher.
So to summarize
what we have so far,
the first statement matches
a floating action button
and clicks it, which should
bring up the Add Note screen.
The second statement
finds the edit text
that lets a user
enter a note title
and verifies that it
is displayed using
the matches view assertion.
Notice that I didn't have
to write any code in between
to wait for previous events
to finish, as Espresso
already takes care
of that for me.
To run the test, I
right-click on the test class
and select Run.
Because it's an
instrumentation test,
it requires an emulator
or physical device.
I can see the actions on
the screen as they execute.
Here's a slightly
longer test that
includes typing into the add
note screen and saving a note,
all using Espresso.
Unless you're writing
end-to-end tests,
you should keep your tests
small and scoped, which
will make them more reliable.
If you want to practice
adding and running
UI tests on your own,
I suggest you check out
our Android Testing Codelab,
which I based this video on.
It contains a
downloadable project
and step-by-step instructions
to get you started.
Join me for the next
episode of Android Testing
Patterns to learn how to handle
adapter views in your tests.
Good luck, and happy testing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]